well I'm joined now by the man that
everyone wants to speak to here in the
blue carpet tonight he's kept us waiting
for 13 years James Cameron come on
what's your excuse me why have we been
waiting no apologies whatsoever no well
the truth of it is I was sitting by the
pool painting my nails for 12 years and
working in a movie for one year right so
I think it's a pretty good work for one
year don't you think yeah
that's the time spent you know working
on the scripts for four movies
production design perform movies a bunch
of new technology we needed to do cool
stuff like that right and uh then we
started Full Tilt five years ago
September of 07 and then we shot two
movies actually part of a part of a
third one so we won't have long to wait
for them one option that's the point
right so three will come out in a couple
years and then four will come out in a
couple years of a boom boom boom right
and that way you won't forget about us
original is Remains the highest grossing
film of all time I mean how much does
that pile the pressure on to you then do
you
the first year was spread crying in the
corner okay no I I don't think about
that it's not you know when you're
working when you're working with amazing
people like like my cast and uh the
artists that I work with to design all
this amazing stuff I just don't think
about it I think about it tonight you
know because you're always reminding me
but it's a three hours plus film isn't
it for the record I've watched three
hours and two minutes of program okay
and then I think half an hour of credits
it doesn't feel like that no it doesn't
right if I know you're being dragged
away
um it does kind of motor along right
yeah you kind of lose track of time
environment
environment film like this do you think
it's going to resonate a bit more look I
think it resonated with the first film
back then a lot of people picked up on
that messaging around the rainforest and
around the the plight of indigenous
cultures around the world we have that
in Spades now because nothing has really
gotten that much better in the meantime
this one is my love letter to to the
oceans and a cry for people everywhere
to to you know be responsible for
guardianship of the oceans so you know
one can always hope that that maybe even
just for a few people that resonates
everybody else can just go on the
adventure and have a good time brilliant
thank you people are really looking
forward to it very nice to meet you
thank you
well it is arguably possibly the most
expensive film that's ever been made
coming in at around 350 now above
Millions rather dollars
um but yeah what what a production what
visual effects that people are going to
see when they head to Cinemas